all devil fruits are cool but some are
definitely weaker than others the dog
dog food model dachshund turns the user
into a human hot dog hybrid sorry but
wiener dogs are not exactly the
definition of overpowered the berry
berry fruit turns its user into a grape
human the minata of One Piece the user
can transform his body into a bunch of
round spheres that look like grapes the
jacket jacket fruit enables its user to
turn into a jacket and then be worn by
other people it is both weak and creepy
at the same time the cook cook fruit
allows its user to turn objects into
food that tastes bad it's like sanji's
nightmare devil fruit finally the
salasala fruit model Axolotl turns the
user into a creature that only lives
underwater but anyone who eats a devil
fruit would drown underwater yikes
subscribe to anime uproar for more
one-piece videos